i think your work is fundamentally
categorically different from token
because tolkien doesn't have politics
right shire is envisages this place
where no politics exists there's no
political tension really there is this
kind of
settled state that's kind of perfect and
then wickedness comes into the world
which comes from one land and it infects
the rest of the world
whereas politics you're in your world is
everywhere which is what life is like of
course
there is always but there are always
political tensions there is a little
politics in tolkien
i mean to be fair here the even in the
shire uh you know at the end the
scouring of the shire
you know where the shire becomes
corrupted it's it's
saruman comes in under the guise of
sharkey and he corrupts some of the
local hobbits who want power
like the sackville baggins is yeah but
without ceremony it wouldn't be
politicized you see
it takes you see normally the hobbits
are fine they're beyond politics
you know they squabble but there's no
real serious political difficulty is
there
that's the thing yeah i suppose that's
true
you have also politics in uh in gondor
where the the stewards don't want to
give way to the true kings they
they've that's true they've been
stewards for so long that uh they
they they don't what king you know what
k went away
thousands of years ago we're not uh
going for that but it it's true that
it's minimal
and and tolkien um i don't know if he
actually subscribed to it but certainly
lord of the rings
in endorses this uh
thing that you've seen a lot of fantasy
which is the belief that a
a good man will be a good king um
which is a reassuring belief that we
would have uh
we like to think that uh the leaders
that we support
are good men and the leaders that we
oppose are
maybe less good men or in some cases
bad men because they have bad policies
but if you actually look at history it's
far more
you know you can't just say and then
aragorn became king and ruled wisely for
a thousand years you know i want to know
okay what what were aragorn's policies
as king
you know what was his taxation policy
yeah how did he how did he handle
times of famine and things like that
what did he do when two lords
how did he handle the orc problem i mean
yeah exactly and he said
thousands of orcs left over at the end
of the war did it did he campaign on a
policy of genocide yeah
ethnic cleansing of the orcs yeah and
and you know given he was so sullen and
withdrawn how did he persuade anyone to
come along with whatever project he was
trying to achieve
and uh yeah who died made him king
anyway as those
as they say so i've seen you know
studying history um you know you see
great kings who are actually seem to be
pretty loathsome people
but they they're smart in terms of the
policies that they adopt and they
produce
certain prosperity for their kingdoms
and you even see this in the present day
i mean
certainly uh in in america the in my
lifetime i think the
best man ever to be president was jimmy
carter
i mean if you look at jimmy carter's
life here's a man
who's very intelligent you know
very um caring and and compassionate
uh wanted to do the right thing and
everything but he was
a failure as a president he was not a
good president i voted for him the first
time and and
had to go to a third-party candidate
that's when he ran for re-election have
you seen that episode of the simpsons
where they wrecked a statue of jimmy
carter in springfield and people scream
and they go he's history's greatest
monster
that kind of raps into writing no i i
missed that one i missed that one
but it's just the proof it's not enough
to be a good man to be a
to be a good king you need a child well
you need
something it's a process of making
decisions
and sometimes you you get very i mean
you know you look at somebody like
lyndon baines johnson uh you know
another president of my lifetime um
his war on poverty his dream of the
great society is a very idealistic dream
yeah
some conservatives might say well it was
all wrong it was socialist and all that
but
putting that debate aside um if he could
have succeeded in that
he would be remembered like uh lbj and
then the new deal
and uh you know like fdr in the new deal
and all that
um that was his idea to complete the new
deal and to produce a society without
poverty
and want um
[Music]
but then he got sidetracked by the
vietnam war and it completely
destroyed his administration and
destroyed him him i think
and destroyed his historical reputation
so you're trying to do good things on
the one hand
and on the other hand you you get
dragged at this war and you make a
number of the wrong decisions
um i guess the that's a
very long way of saying it's hard to be
the king or the president
it's hard to know the right thing to do
and there are unintended consequences
to every decision that you make and you
know
people rise up in opposition whose ox is
being gored and
and uh this stuff fascinates me and i'd
love to write about it so it's very much
a part of
of westerosa the decisions are not easy
like do the good thing and do the bad
thing if you do
sometimes if you do the good thing
there's going to be lots of nasty
consequences to you and yours
so maybe you should do the bad thing or
try to figure out some third thing to do
and i want to grapple with all of that
so yeah politics is is definitely part
of it what do you think of that edict
write about what you know that writer's
edit that's told to everyone who goes to
writing school
write about what you know i mean there'd
be no
game of thrones if that were true
wouldn't it you know yes and no
when i was when i first heard that when
i was a young writer as a kid and i
heard that i was very
um troubled by that comment because uh
i didn't want to just write about a kid
growing up in the projects i wanted to
write about other worlds i wanted to
write
science fiction and and fantasy um
i didn't want to write autobiographical
fiction but i i
i think as i have gotten older and i got
a little deeper understanding of writing
and i think there's great truth to that
but it doesn't have to be taken
literally it doesn't mean that if you're
you know raised in if you're
born and raised in brisbane you can only
write about some kid being born and
raised in brisbane in the 70s i know
what would it be if you just wrote about
new jersey in the 60s
yeah right yeah um well it would be i
mean that's a valid thing to do there
there are some writers who are who are
terrific at that
um where about in my my jean cocteau
theater we have authors in too and
as soon as i get back from this trip
we're having pat conroy an amazing
writer one of the great american writers
of our time i think
and his work is hugely autobiographical
he he's
almost everything he writes you can see
the specter of his abusive father
in in it um you know the great santini
uh his new book is the death of santini
but even in things like prince of tides
and all that
um and that's great you know you can you
can do that but you can also do the
other thing and certainly my
my life the things i know uh
do give my fiction its power you know
there's there's a lot of me and tyrion
lannister
there's a lot of me and samwell tarly or
even in characters like arya or
or daenerys you know feelings i've had
ways of looking at the world
and and what you know doesn't always
mean what you've experienced too i know
a lot of things because i've read about
them in books because i've studied
history because i've studied
literature and you know read all the
great writers who've gone before me
that's stuff i know
too so when write what you know those
are things i know and it's all grist for
the mill
how about the other dictum which is to
find for a writer you should find the
area
of your greatest pain and write about
that
uh yeah that's probably true
who said that oh i don't know that's
something that's been floating around
for a while
yeah and that that that way when you're
you my friend of mine said this
you're most vulnerable that's when
you're almost at your strongest in a
funny way as a writer
well i guess i think that's true um you
know you there's a question of writing
from the
writing from the head or writing from
the heart
and i think great literature is written
from the heart or some people would say
it's written from the guts
or the balls or wherever you want but
but it it
it has you know writing fiction in
particular is about emotion
you sometimes see science fiction called
the literature of ideas but really if
you want to argue ideas write essays
write nonfiction that's the best thing
to do ideas
uh to express an idea and way arguments
um
fiction is about emotion you know you
can write a anti-slavery tract
um as many abolitionists did in the uh
in the 1840s and the 1850s but if you
really want to make a case of slavery
you write uncle tom's cabin
and you punch people in the in the gut
and you make it
you create characters and you make an
emotional case that's what that's what
fiction is all about
the emotions